[Music]
what up
it's Tony trip want to let you guys know
that I have a shop out here in Chicago
called maven it's a men's clothing store
it's a boutique and we're also online
and I want you guys to check it out and
for our listeners we're offering 15% off
a checkout if you enter the promo code
Rambler you get 15% off of anything that
tickles your fancy
that's maven shop comm ME yvn shop.com
and then to Rambler a check out and get
15% off storewide get dip get the chicks
holla there there are a lot of things
that can stress you out or get you down
have you ever thought about going to
therapy but found it so inconvenient too
expensive or just too embarrassing to
make it into an office then give talk
space a trial talk space is the online
therapy company and they make it easy to
connect with a licensed therapist
handpicked just for you for as little as
thirty two dollars a week using talk
space you could tax audio and video
message your therapist as much as you
want your talk space therapist to listen
to you vent about work relationships
family everything and puts you on the
path to a half of your life to sign up a
learn more go to talk space.com slash
Hannibal has a special offer to our
listeners you can use coupon code and
I'm gonna get $30 off your first month
cold
Hannibal talk space.com slash Hannibal
talk space therapy for how we live today
[Music]
yep yep you're starting it up look just
start it up
stop starting it up start starting it up
smart Monroe you know
welcome to now that was out Hanson
travel the podcast that's Tony trim on
the drums over there on the beat Brian
Babylon here yeah
special guests excited to have them from
Chicago one of my oldest friends and
comedy please welcome we try to lift the
spirits with the cause probably a week
from today we'll put this out but right
now is Friday April 28th as we record
sales 28 and we just watch the Bulls get
dusted by the cells it's not even think
the game is fully over yet but it's over
it's over
oh man 30 points that I was adjusted
Michael I had to stay at your TV like
maybe throw my eyes it was all so blurry
yeah it was I was hoping it says 64 uh
it was it was rough man
it was it was terrible cuz it we it was
so exciting the Bulls were up to O on
the Celtics one of those two games in
ball emboss the thing was they won those
involved in Boston first two games
people were hyped everybody was hyped
all [ __ ]
look at Boston they number one seed we
number eight it was looking right don't
hurt do it man and that changed
everything actually they started playing
slower the bull should have kept running
a basketball man and it couldn't run
with Isaiah Canaan we had our own Isiah
was not as strong yeah he's kind of he's
kind of okay worst version of a bj
Armstrong was Wow BJ BJ Armstrong with
the barrel chest because I'm saying I
really believe that I thought the Bulls
gonna like get it together people on the
bench don't step on that was I thought
the Bulls I saw little rails
motivational coach speech don't have to
be to blame now for this because they
didn't get blown out like that until I
made a motivation yeah I was I was
scrolling through Instagram today and
yeah you you did a speech and the mo
speakerphone was a motivational speech
and I thought it was it was it was first
when I did two videos the first one was
too real and they told me we can't take
two
yeah so I had to do it again where I was
more motive the first I look what are
you doing I would just met with nothing
without Rondo it was like no we can't
[Music]
I'll be ruined
I feel like you should use butter say
everybody on one knee everybody on one
needs that word a lot of things that
people so I grab my jersey net ashore
Chicago and people thought I play with
my nipples which is like why would I do
this here's my theory brought the Bulls
and the way they played today
what's up did look at Instagram you
didn't they didn't look at instead they
just see this goddamn video playing like
garbage I love little rels Instagram by
the way he's one of my favorite people
superstar you you made very late when
you have your thing in your name
Ralphie's is a thing no more Ralphie's
why not cuz weird and people now making
more comments that I don't like it was
difficult just have followers of people
I knew it was always nice things or
maybe a few jokes here that you know you
got these dicks to say anything a man I
will fight you Fran like you go to my
Instagram live and be insane yeah I'll
be roasted I'll be tell be like I mean
is [ __ ] it is right to this though in
between it yeah cuz the get out get out
is crazy they get out there yeah
it hadn't change the game a bit that was
he was your legend you can once you get
into the movie that hot and he become
the person in that movie when my mama
know you my mom I don't know [ __ ]
well my mama no you Oh Brown like him
nice funny let you that [ __ ] been it's
been weird and crazy and [ __ ]
what's teenagers be [ __ ] losing yeah
oh yeah teenagers anything so excited
yeah and I be chilling so it's not like
you got some people that draw there put
your hand by it it makes music like some
of my hands so much if this was in my
house everybody be all [ __ ] up these
teenagers they insane and [ __ ] they just
they just always have a lot of energy
yeah it throws you off with somebody
when you yeah when somebody just is to
you it makes you uncomfortable makes you
uncomfortable to make sure you and not
but you they're young so you don't want
to be meaning right no the funniest
thing that says it to airplanes this
nice African family that kept looking at
me yeah evening it's a red are you the
guy from keep tapping like yes community
but they children are the kids and a
little [ __ ] I was a whole you were no
soon I will show you this 15 you that is
a very good point Africans like to take
pictures what iPad is love I've seen
multiple Africans at concerts
at that bobby womack concert yeah it was
I was thinking Bobby I forgot she was
[Music]
[Laughter]
funny did you breathe that was amazing
man that was one of the best like if so
everybody would eat open it across 100
it was it was his last show as long as
last shows he died like a few years
later they did a pop-up festival it was
like a circus tent they put up at the
old Tribune wherever it was like near
japonais it was like it was old [ __ ]
and hipsters it was old [ __ ] hipsters
they have like those the matching shirt
and pants no yes I would dress like
there was yes that's so weird that's the
first thing I was a hipster go match
yeah it was a great show the hipsters
would sit down Obie was they all know
Blackie was sitting down but you can see
I ever take white hipsters yeah yeah Oh
Blackie would and I think I think the
hipsters was wanted him to do a lot of
his new stuff which was weird but and he
did all his hits I'm doing all for my
people it was great man it was a great
show I bought that ticket in Africa I
had literally came straight from the
airport
yeah I don't even see my family yet
where do you do that in Africa that
means you a fan yeah oh I'm sorry
somebody Facebook
nah click oh [ __ ] my ticket one [ __ ]
ticket last concert I saw designer in
Orlando Florida oh yeah what was that
was it how many songs you get he has a
lot of songs um he has crazy energy his
energy that looks maybe goofy on
Instagram video is extremely captivating
in person he's like the most animated
right yeah you see that [ __ ] on your
phone this [ __ ] is stupid if Percy like
wow really loves rapid it's crazy energy
like where you like water sucess water
you know what I've Nvidia you texted us
of that show yeah I just well I just
posted that on Instagram
I've been watching that video it's like
maybe 7 8 seconds yeah I've watched that
video at least noise ships the designer
show that he wants to do some stuff to
definitely work out in us but as far as
just energy energy a performance is some
next-level stuff man how long did it
take before we took his shirt off but I
don't think there so there are designer
fans cuz look like people would err who
knew that song I never heard of it
no yeah a lot of songs I didn't know but
he still carry the vibe meaning it's
tough with rap to get over when you open
people don't know every song people is
just stand still but if you feel like a
song even if it's jay-z or knives if
you're not filling that particular track
you kind of just kind of all right this
is time check my email real quick and
then you know I got I know I can't do
what I want to be
[Music]
and the song you like comes on then you
check back in a couple but it was
stopped early because I already know a
couple a couple of his songs but he was
going in all I know it's Panda
yeah timmy turner what was that Jimmy
Jimmy Jimmy chunga Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy G
lariat immaturity return somebody did a
spoof of that of like a slave lady
dancing that was really funny to that
Timmy Donna's long it was funny yeah so
yeah I'm an edited future the
performance works yes
as a future as hits the hits the hits
carry future yes oh I'm gonna tell you
that I went to that Drake future concert
maybe he came out so hard I was just
going off of how he how he popped on the
stage and an explosion he came out at
rapping then he decide yeah I don't know
I don't know if he had that type of
designer and if you don't know I mean
the times I've seen futures been in way
this was actually this design it was a
few hundred people there it wasn't
packed out I was trying to finagler
finesse for tickets cuz I thought it
would be crazy and then I I just I got
to the venue and then just walk up and
bought tickets yeah isn't that a big
[ __ ] what is going on it but it was a
Monday in Orlando so maybe that's oh no
future is a solid but the hits he got
the bangers where the [ __ ] just come on
and everybody got a good show yeah but
it was we were together heartbeat
weekend with Drake did that show o at
that uh at the Cosmopolitan
I was at that yeah yeah he was Drake
hits and that's what I'm saying last
when we saw that Coachella when Kendrick
came out and I asked you like his
healing stage yet he had been on stage
for like five minutes because you said
something wrong with the sound yeah well
no we were so [ __ ] far away that you
couldn't even see the all you saw was
the screens we were so far away you
couldn't even it wasn't loud enough or
was draped efficient yeah March 1st like
yeah [ __ ] about him
like the old black people was kind of
like alright let's keep ulama yeah it
will
it was in the flesh it was in the
Superdome yeah which is a football
stadium true and I don't think as far as
essence Fest Kendrick Lamar not a
football stadium packed here smoothie
king center act yeah which is not it's
20,000 P is 15 the 20,000 people versus
80,000 people yeah and so yeah it was
just as far as 80,000 you gotta have big
songs too big song big song a new issue
I think no Justin would kill essence
fast
I think chance gonna kill he's dead he's
gonna have a choir he's gone everything
that oh yeah can we talk about we just
we just went and saw his magnificent
color and day too
no way does a little secret thing were
you there you didn't go to night and go
I wanted to go I got funny bad that
takes chance you invited me to his
birthday party and I get them I couldn't
get in really the one day I was in
Chicago oh no studio Paris yeah yeah you
know I promise you I should be in there
like Chicago is well about Chicago it a
humble [ __ ] out of you yeah get it all I
may get to everything I want in LA nice
Akali like I don't give a [ __ ] what you
did to forget it
Oh enjoyed you know movie
[Laughter]
it was probably the big black guy said
it may be the one that stopped me was
the one I do do I do totally what was
their reason for not letting you in it
was crazy it was insanely packed but I'm
like one more do you see well you see
like six broke-ass chicks go in it's
like what the [ __ ] man yeah what are you
like then that come on then that it's
Lisa like these girls right
the race Jill your race shows good
you've got it guys did it you need to
even it up a little bit but do you
apologize I thought Meg can I get out of
control and it's an animai well yeah he
did you know but yeah he posted a post
about it on his Instagram anyone so far
I almost wasn't sure cuz I've never been
to your parents I've seen day parties
there but I've ever been in so I'm
thinking that is a bigger thing I'm like
I get that like bright you couldn't have
your party this is what you did this
that yeah that's like a private friends
only okay is right super any posted on
his Instagram for charity so you have to
pay to get in there probably a lot of
people for tickets and race my age it
was the tables is like 2500 3000 there
you go make money
yeah well that Harold's birthday cake
there that's what I want to see how I
was that wherever he was at before yeah
[ __ ]
but yeah we went to that we wanted a
magnificent day to and it was like it
some undisclosed warehouse space on the
south side mm-hm
and it was crazy there was like [ __ ]
like four or five stages like full like
backdrops like dancing bands choir and
this [ __ ]
his energy was I
so he's running literally running across
these stages what his life this is live
tour is gonna be no I think he was
filled
I think he's filming that for something
I already got a spear for a special for
dead right think that's probably looks
like it was yeah because there was like
straight up like jigs and like big-ass
colony I was like and they were set up
in all different angles so they were
definitely filming that for something
one of the best concerts I've been to
was this concert I saw here no it's not
a good show man it was such a good a
show man I enjoyed the [ __ ] out of it
I mean I've ever cut one of my children
Kanye's when college dropout came uh
that's the first one right cuz Trevor
yeah yeah and he did a show at House of
Blues and it was just you never get that
energy of Chi yeah I had my CD with me
they never did no [ __ ] like that but as
I went those moments just proud of
Chicago and it's like yeah [ __ ] this
dude did it like Calle at that time to
me feel like somebody you knew that made
it and then the craziest part is he was
always in the cut before he started like
he was in the music video for get him
girls from camera you know he was in the
background yeah he's in the he's in the
crew just like okay hit him girls that's
like what night that's 90's isn't it
early to that [ __ ] yeah yeah he's in
that video just in the cut with the
posse yeah spotted the dragon without
Putin what was a dragon room was the
name of that spot with John monopoly and
on his head in parties over there yeah
was it the dragon rack that's it was it
was called biology biology biology I
remember that is can we used to go now
promote eyes nice to go out with DeRay
yeah remote riddled [ __ ]
and I could pull of girls back trying to
invite it to the show we had to be
Raley's put our names on the flyer
a lot of people don't know my second
time on stage ever was in 2002 in
Carbondale was on the show with Laura
why my second show ever first was this
open mic at the in a big muddy room SIU
second was a show with little real
triple team did triple team productions
did that show Kevin from triple team put
that on and rail was headlining was
michio net
I was Wildcat and I think make it two
phases Shady's was one thing that stood
out to me about that show in that day
there was after party at whatever spot
and I was 19 at the time and I was
talking with over at laughter - oh hey
man you won't want a beer you know yeah
I have a corona and he gave me a Corona
and I had the Corona I was like damn
comedies don't you do a show you hang
out you get a beer 15 years later
borderline alcohol like DeRay bought me
my first drink I didn't drink it till I
was 21 that was the first riddles Wow so
that's me Kanye's to come there yeah
that place was legendary man I remember
going there to do a show and I came to I
drove all the way up there from the city
and I came out and they like couches
outside they got evicted yeah I was like
damn well you was he left you know they
just fellow made all that money for
their nature act like you
but this one be [ __ ] if he wouldn't make
it like dear I'm a an insane amount of
money every week did ya like it here
pocket like 20 stacks Wow
3 shows sold out charges like 30 like
how did the last laugh crew start Lu
Michi and Wow how did that DeRay gave us
that night yeah so we were just all
hanging we roommates and you know Michi
was already working with Dhiren and he
brought us along with him and we know
he's helping promote the shows I just do
that so I can go up whatever it's a seed
in riddles so I can do stage time every
week I remember like comics picking on
me like look at you stupid as hell you
seen oh you mean like like uh sure yeah
that's literally set people down and
then I did a spot yeah I did that just
so I can go up every weekend then and
what's the girl quit I was like can I
have $50 and he was given a $50 I got
stage time who's the girl
the store girl it was a model chick at
the taifa kind of [ __ ] night you know
she's still fine - I forgot her name but
she had left and let me get up $50 a
week and I was seating and going up but
it was so funny like what comedians let
her talk [ __ ] about it was like I wanted
stage time and right hottest spot
[ __ ] like so why wouldn't I do
that and bam used to drive me there's a
fat comedian named BAM live with Marcus
BAM was it BAM Henderson Bam Bam Bam you
know did he uh do you live in Gary no I
wanted cuz BAM our cousin band what band
was from out west
just like mica Weiser drive from the
west side we used to take Cicero yeah
all the way 200 Street yeah he would
travel to expressway he wouldn't drive
on his person that's one ticket Cicero
to a hundred fifty thousand Eve early
was his car terrible
no he had a Lincoln laughing it was
Oh like an old person's Lincoln it was
new
yeah and wouldn't
that's a terrible routes don't know
Chicago geography that's a that you
don't have to go that what you can use
you options and the old days what street
you gotta take Halsted the Ford
expressways Halsted went all the way
from the city of Chicago Heights and
[ __ ] like that yeah people just take
Halsted most places don't have no [ __ ]
like that that goes that like even with
LA here you know Pico can be so many
different types of way it cuts off with
it starts over in Chicago you go down
anybody visit I'm not saying do this but
if you if you just want to see if we
line and I just go to Cicero and like
Madison and some and just keep going
straight and see if I you can go you
know your behavior to kill really you're
really almost go from Chicago on Cicero
almost to [ __ ] Urbana it's just a big
grid almost a huge grid from one point
to the other if you just keep driving
well yeah you could take Milwaukee
haven't you could take it up to
Milwaukee I think you can I'm I'm making
that up
no I think you're right right I think
you want to keep going world village
know that forty it's either 45 but it
turns into a number you know how about
we get excited about intersections oh
you're kidding Armitage in Central Park
the hugs everything about Milwaukee I
want to do
like I'm gonna try to try to MIT walking
from your walking leave like 5 a.m.
you'll get there ah same was like she's
light traffic I think two hours two
hours two to two-and-a-half times if you
believe early yeah you know his beat-up
car - you remember the guy used to drive
yeah use that as terrible car
I had a few drove over to Peoria at
Kevin Williams Club yeah the comedy club
box comedy box rather it was either the
Ford Escort or the the Volvo was in
better state oh oh yes I remember that
Volvo it was one of them I was always
scared that it might that might have
been my stop the hand-me-downs the
jukebox in Peoria that room that would
use to be that was a Sunday room yeah
Kevin Williams is remember Kevin we have
the glasses yeah it's my either eBay
could be amazing or really hard I
remember doing a guest spot there and
did y'all come back the same night from
Peoria yeah I did a guest spot
what'd you do five six minutes and then
uh Kevin he said he wanted to book me
for 30 minutes do 400 bucks I saw 150
bucks I'm like that and I was like yeah
even though I did not have that amount
of time I was like what I get into
comedy 30 minutes hundred dollars and so
then I started calling him like yes so
we still good for it and then I guess he
might have heard that I do not have that
you beaucoup like like poor people did
that dinner yeah
you know driving for like two and a half
hours for like $150 like I'm feeling
yeah I think I went to Vincennes Indiana
from Carbondale
I skipped class on that [ __ ] and went to
playtest Club Rome's comedy club and
maybe hosted three shows and got a
hundred fifty total and on the way
driving I had to stop to get gas and
then it was one of those prepaid so I'm
not a free prese you can just pump and
then pay and I pumped and then my credit
card was the client still in gas
Millennials will never know about that
that thing the joy of like reparations
you still get oh I'm done with the
college in Atlanta
yeah so I would drive back and forth
from and I did that [ __ ] in the south
that's dangerous
yeah that's really good to the gate
still in anything a little chain gang
for thing I've still gas I and - you
guys ever do that once I think about
doing it now though yeah just to just to
get the blood going yeah yeah I guess
what a [ __ ] fat person didn't realize
I didn't think it out like I was even
what to do who was fat and he's not
running first and then I got outside
running and then I'm like [ __ ] you
right here like I've been you'd left
five minutes ago like he was big as [ __ ]
so do it with people in shape because if
you Dennis were handsome rambling diner
- tomorrow
you know one of my my favorite bits is
when you talk about being on the bus and
getting roasted by the teenager
oh no the roast battle wouldn't know
their batteries out here oh hey you feel
good of you in Chicago man
I've been trying to do like you know
stuff because I'm back home just to feel
it but then you'd be like nah maybe I
shouldn't do that like like I end up
getting on the bus
I felt like [ __ ] this is one day like
you know Marui municipal rather Jax and
Buster's just think about life that
reminiscent lasted two stops I was
reminiscing for to stop something out
sort of high-school kids get all that
guy I know I did it again no it's about
that they don't give a damn what is this
even the 1560s Waddell roaster shot us
my dad was having a freestyle batter on
a bus and I was the punchline I even
know I was gonna rock with the heads and
said that you ain't [ __ ] like do right
there
[Applause]
like buddy right there grab my clothes
[ __ ] I'm really happy to die happy to
survive it did happen and it was like I
think that's the nice version of it yeah
all staged but it like because when they
did it then it was like real lyrics like
he was going there and he's down and it
is just went to them roasted me yeah
like we're from battle ins like like
roasted me like their buddy he scared is
it like it was like because I would say
that I shake it yeah ain't nobody gonna
hurt you a little here there's like it
was way longer stop wrap it the rest
means other passengers laughing at you
not really like people were scared
everybody was I was like if you start
laughing for like the teenagers gonna
talk about you though it's like if
you've ever had a real rose of that it
was somebody and you laugh to art and
then they get mad at you like why don't
you ain't laugh yeah that's I think
everybody will talk about that feeling
but if you see it five teenagers like
what they gonna say about me man revert
back to high school maybe because they
mean we need to just start roasting
teenagers and filming it brain are weird
cuz life is so am i but wait list you
are a no use filters like that anything
Facebook is for old people but is really
a great tool still you don't have a dime
and you broke your parents that today
you wouldn't know me win it
if your hair is dead today I still take
public transportation at the crib no I
can't no you can't walk to him I had
some I went and it's before get out it
was just like cuz you I think I'm a
chain on and up there I was comforting
every other I don't feel like I just
take the train look out the window and
that's subway you can see people
plotting to rob you I still still street
smart enough to know when that's
happening
ya know where new before these two
months cuz I know they planning it they
know exactly we stop and try to get me
at like you know white people leaving
one of the stuff that's when I got off
and I remember him I remember seeing him
look at me like I'm never doing this
again cuz they will get me make it they
what was that you just saw was it a look
or did they move it was a living it was
seen over as well it was a look and it
was like that she liked that they not
talking but they talking [ __ ] like
making faces yeah yeah I hate that
feeling
yeah I'm not having me like once and I
was like I just gave it look like man
come on cuz I know me and I'm not gonna
just back down with my stupid ass I'm
gonna battle these [ __ ] and die let me
just get out this and not do this every
game these are the time you can't eat a
chain oh yeah I so take the train but
I'm not famous or anything so it's easy
for me to get Tony trim so what it's the
best way to get back and forth from the
airport I'd say Eddie really is I don't
I will never like if I'm late at night
I'll take it oh just something but I
will blue line that [ __ ] in her yeah it
takes yeah it cuz I used to live right
by California Fullerton and it literally
and that's right Yeah right there right
off the California stop BAM
they should be no zero you'll be too
crazy I don't know I just won a lot of
time
I'll map it out I'll Google map it out
and it's way could it be in a car yeah
it is yeah in Chicago in New York
sometimes yeah you can take the train in
New York well about Jordan everybody be
so focused on whatever the [ __ ] they got
to do sometimes yeah they don't give a
[ __ ]
especially if it's doing work hours
ain't nobody [ __ ] I can attack
everybody's trying to [ __ ] you can be on
fire and nobody's paying attention ooh
yes but that city gets like gridlocked
and sometimes you just have to take the
just like yo that's not you guys car
ain't getting nowhere you get in a car
to go do something and it was like that
was down the street which I could have
walked to yeah for like an outlet like
this is [ __ ] ridiculous why don't you
get out I will say this in New York I
will say this in New York would you stay
in the car if he was going somewhere and
it was because you know New York gets
steamy and you get sweaty in that film
of just gross
I was stay in the car for extra if his
air conditioner nasty like New York New
York is one of my favorite most
spontaneous I was able to be a very I
like I remember one Sunday I was out of
chicken we went to church then we saw a
play then we went to Dallas barbecue
then we went to a day party we saw a
band I like making dishes of it like
that but this isn't one [ __ ] day and
was a planos always something popping in
New York it's like if you can't find
something to do then you're an idiot
there's always just like a rom-com on
tossed as you do subscribe for soul you
know search mmm day parties may
condition this girl oh this is a great
date it was a fella was in took a
failure and she was like the musical
yeah the musical on Broadway if she was
into Dan
then we went to the Knicks game wait the
same day same day Wow failure magnate
Knicks game and then tape and S&L that's
good that's correct
hey did you smash it there two minutes
and sleep honestly I would say cuz I
have a sister I was like you know got
some others like man I'm people doing
now she gets a [ __ ] that supports rape
culture don't you know I thought my
sister a big cousin think about you
dinner you can [ __ ] him but fail I mix
game that's an SNL taping anyway I like
do you like them that's what I'm saying
well do you like him already
yeah I would never first date you only
get one wait a minute first date you
don't if anyone is podcast does that on
the first date you're an [ __ ] but if
you take a girl do those three if it's
Beyonce if that's a if it's be honest I
think it'd be honest I'm amazed at first
dates as well like when I don't call a
female back at Sonny let you know they
get out man and weird but I'm like women
don't realize that you want to enjoy
yourself - yeah I'm not really doing all
this [ __ ] just because I don't want to
do it so [ __ ] wants to go to the museum
by themselves yeah you take the girl and
then you know the girl automatically
thinks that you're just doing this to
smash but it's like no I want to look at
art with no like I took you to Universal
Studios I get free life passes you think
that's because I want to make sure you
feel [ __ ] that I don't want to wait in
this [ __ ] line that's a high-octane
day bro it was a lot actually I don't
know I don't think we had sex that night
because I was exhausted wait you better
tell me you meet you miss grad a dream
dream date she hate got all those things
and even held her on I was kidding I
mean yeah
sometimes it's not about morning it's
always morning sounds great man you just
got back from table read Carmichael show
episode that we're doing it Kevin Barney
and Josh Rabinowitz room oh [ __ ]
Barnett Rabinowitz yeah so yeah this is
it for season three we almost done we
come back on TV May 31st okay we excite
this doramas saying this today we was
talking about it he feels like this is
the best like this season three could be
one of the greatest seasons a television
just because of what we're doing this
[ __ ] is insane I don't think nobody's
gonna try to copy it if you do this it's
just weird because it's very edgy and
crazy
no spoilers the more I think about it I
just like oh yeah this is the best
season I think do you help with that
there's in the writing and stuff at all
not on purpose yeah you know I think
when you have conversations with your I
mean your personal [ __ ] and yeah look at
the script yeah season two they just put
up the first two seasons on Netflix yeah
that's how easy makes it easy
Netflix makes it easy for people that's
the thing and it helps that's what it
benefits to me even more shows that's on
television already looking binge
watching ketchup if they don't show
reruns no [ __ ] water right Netflix is
one of those places are people allowed
to go to to watch shows it and I like
literally it's been people every day
online just like oh where did this come
from was like so you just made a good
point they don't show [ __ ] reruns
normally don't because they don't we
don't want to pay you for this [ __ ]
boom
I mean you'll get reruns if your show
gets syndicated but they don't do it on
not and that's an answer that be at a
certain amount late cancel [ __ ] past now
they only giving you late 13 days like
that means no obstacles to get to that
country they make it yeah we're used to
be 20 it's 22 episodes for a season yeah
yeah 24 you get four or five see four
seasons and you into the fifth that's a
hundred right there and you get those
dollars those rid that passive income I
heard I heard an old Hollywood you know
stay away gave I like Ted Danson when he
hit his hundred on cheers or whatever
they gave him like a Porsche yeah or
some and then Roseanne when she hit her
hundred they gave her like a real big
bar of chocolate and she was pissed off
damn what the [ __ ] is this that's my
[ __ ] portion you gave me a chocolate
way the Roseanne show broken glass you
are you watch the other get down
[Laughter]
yeah I watch the first get the first
part of the first thing the second one
is kind of weird I don't know if I like
you to be honest with you I'm not all
the way caught up what was weird about
it
to get down Giraud described it best
today by say it's real jazz handy and it
is is this everything everything's like
this is like weird [ __ ] performances
in I don't know I don't like it I don't
know why me don't know if I saw
something else that maybe I like more
you know what I think makes you I don't
know I'm gonna tell ya pyramid flow is
the best
[Music]
there's got to be a bit about to do who
made a computer love thing weird as
black dude yeah so for the West Side of
Chicago
savers me and how you built an
incredible crazy following in Chicago
over the years what was that just
through killing shoulders do it
aggressive marketing where the mouth or
how do you think it got to that point
where you were kind of the city's
comedian before the actors popping off
and before cuz I remember explaining to
industry folks I remember talking to
three arts and and Becky and I'm saying
little real is the dude like this dude
is got the buzz of Bernie Mac in Chicago
I was stammers and that's what made this
phone call with Chris Rock I might have
told you about this but like he called
me I never talked Christmas for like
this but Holly he'll hit me somebody
give me such as such as no it's not a
people for numbers in the end he called
me and I guess somebody told me to watch
my Netflix special yeah Jermaine Fowler
playing like dude stop [ __ ] playing
in saint-germain and we just got to
talking [ __ ] [ __ ] okay I gave it to
me alright but he was just saying like I
remind him a Burnie like he's like are
you his nephew or something like no so
you just remind me of Bernie you got
this [ __ ] rush and he went through
all the bits and all that [ __ ] and that
was kind of weird to even what are you
saying it I which is well I actually
looked at the blueprint of what Bernie
did in Chicago and DeRay it was the
first it was a tunnel
d razor first want to do that this
Hustle thing which it was it's a lot of
things d raiders about self-promoting
that I took and did when I got my own
[ __ ] yeah like where your name on your
shirt you sure you [ __ ] pass that
dude use a pass off flies at the metro
station
yeah show so people come off going like
so you just had the grind I used to do
rate passing out flyers he's where he's
working Baker she and I used to see him
on State Street when I would be at lunch
of my job Sierra takes to Chicago
everywhere and I did that so what helped
me the specially I got jokes and notes I
started giving away my comedy CDs the
chicks cuz you know girl Chicago chicks
a mean to you you ain't funny put the CD
in there you know and I always listen to
and I have my number in there and
they'll call me will you be it and then
I did there and then like instead of the
street hustle myspace is popping at the
time so every two days it took me two
days straight
48 hours of message and only girls
that's what I did that for is only
chicks come see me another just to pack
it in and I know once they saw me is
like word amount happen but it's and
it's going now and it's a lot of [ __ ] to
go it to that [ __ ] but I was excited I
create that buzz of Chicago man and like
that's when they started looking for
like [ __ ] like people by Bob some of
them they came for like def Comedy Jam
or some of the showcase and they come
[ __ ] is is do I didn't go crazy like
that we've never heard of them but its
crisis mark see so you lock down the
female audience first cuz do that come
wherever female yeah that's what I'm
saying women love to laugh jokes
I'll get Oh chicks care about it just
having a good time that's all anyone to
his party let me tell you our true story
I had a really good year this year and I
used to drink Moscato right but who
rents toted Moscato used to be a classy
drink these would be a classy [ __ ] let
me take my bow to her ass told I was at
the liquor store right and I even walk
in yet and it was a whole group of men
they're like you know you we got a scene
here now you can see if you just seated
uh-oh here we go and I think it was a
fad here at Berkeley let me say this
now she thought she looked dope because
this was who rescued they got a terrible
friend they'd be lying to the frame with
the bad body like she colorize your
birthday and you can't bang every chick
bad chick to cover your show you learn
that early like it's such a weird thing
what else be a comedian especially if
you become a popular one when you can't
understand you just fantasy tournament
[ __ ] when you [ __ ] them you know you
[ __ ] all that up yeah you know they
stopped inviting a girl like if you
don't [ __ ] them they'd keep bringing
girls with girls so you just got
sections a bit like comics is always
because I always promote it to them and
I promote it outside of comedy clubs to
a lot of comics don't do that
you mean I was weird to go I mean you
like you go to somebody else show to
promote your show that's a cool but it's
dumb to me I went to the clubs or [ __ ]
you know go to comedy shows like I look
at my homies dope dealer friends you
know I sort of develop into comedy kind
of sewers jokes and notes like Maddie go
to show them like you had to be a good
[Laughter]
it's just interesting that says
Chicago's a huge part of just you know
coming out here and really giving me
confidence to be [ __ ] eyes what you
like they made me feel like a star
before all this [ __ ] which is well I'm
like real chill about everything but I
feel like a star of Chicago man jokes
and nose was out man those first years
man when you when he was hosting open
mic went down Carlos no but Mike here
you know if saying TJ metal would be
coming in there and when it first popped
off it was crazy man yeah I mean it was
it was like a mission Wednesday to this
to Sunday it was like it was poppin
it was it was it was a it was a classic
I mean I had so much fun that's still
what am i I hate that it's not here I
didn't like the before my United it's a
club now to you know that Renaissance
yeah Renaissance yeah yeah at least kept
the faces up I haven't been in that work
every time I walk by I'll make you
afraid to go in there man you are weird
to like I want to see it what a brother
that crying crying do you want a drink
[Music]
stress you out like get you down have
you thought about therapy but you don't
want to go into an office or look
somebody in the eyes talk space is for
you talk spaces new online therapy
company they connect you with a licensed
therapist for as little as thirty two
dollars a week
you could text audio video message your
therapist and they'll get back to you
and listen to you vent about whatever
work family relationships all that to
sign up or learn more go to talk
space.com slash Hannibal that's a
special offer for our listeners you can
use coupon code aníbal to get $30 off
your first month and show your support
for this podcast that's cold Hannibal by
visiting talk space.com slash Hannibal
talk space therapy for how we live
[Music]
yet I did a show I was doing the run at
Zanies 2011 maybe in 2011 and it was a
pop we did a pop-up like the last-minute
things for all ages at reckless Records
on Milwaukee dam and so afterwards me
and lo real was walking down the block
and then it was people were recognizing
this video he was white people only
white people were coming up to me that's
the range that's the range that was I
like the people don't think I don't
think comedians are friends like they'd
be surprised like you a lot with me if
I'm making our comic this way know each
other yeah we all do we can't we can all
comedians yeah yeah it's a good chance
we will probably meet yeah hey blow she
had him real of friends I think the last
show I think the last show we did
i rails doing mo bettah Mondays they're
from and so I just kind of been in the
hotel all days I saw that railways
performing let me just pop out have a
couple of drinks watch the show kickin I
didn't want to go up I just wanted to
and this is Dee race night race night
yeah diri asked me to go and no I said
no I'm just gonna chill out and go on a
showroom and then real go on he was real
was the last comedian we all go along
and kicks it he kills kills it
crowds laughing is good energy I'm just
chillin then DeRay go back up we got a
special guest everybody Hannibal Burres
then so I got it I gotta go up I don't
know if he thought I thought I don't
know if he's trying to catch me slip in
a sub he was testing me or whatever it
was
DeRay crazy cuz I asked him that I said
out I said I wanna do this but if
somebody tell me they don't want to do
this fight right I go up you I can't not
go up if you call my name that's even
more awkward than you guys that's a town
we don't care fun yeah you love to
challenge you man you've been doing
that's just how to put you why he's put
me up behind some [ __ ] just to prove
I don't know what
you know it's funny because we and they
class there was a lot more competitors
insanely competitive like maniacs so who
are the holes in that class you're
talking about I mean you come out when I
first started it was like and this was
in Chicago right see I remember doing my
first show Damon show they put up
DeRay Corey Holcomb Jeff B Marlon
Mitchell Jade the Audis ACOG obese
winner and destroyed it at David like
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you stopped playing someone please call
now oh yeah play your ass up he has a
bomb playlist of songs that you play
with just one establishes some as some
comedy clubs usually a black comedy
night or club if you're not doing well
the DJ will just play music to make you
stop even if you haven't reached your
schedule set side a mean song and a mean
not not just a song to play on was my
favorite I'd even lead a club that's
what I meant meet you for the first time
yeah he came in I was sitting I was a
shock just looking at the stage with a
weird grin on my face he's a hit man he
can't be doing it in a corner here
do you remember what this is some of the
jokes you were doing the early [ __ ] how
do you really get into it yeah it was
like the way I reacted to the lady
yelling at me and they got mad at me for
[ __ ] the 50 bucks oh yeah
there's no leeway when you really start
now not a lot of leeway you gotta kill
right away ya ever seen in my life
yeah it was good because it was to this
day yeah never seen nobody everything I
got shoes like Walter Payton restaurant
no was it like some little bit yeah man
but he was the man he was a man in the
roaring Kankakee for like this first two
years ago Wow he was do it all like the
recovery drug addict shows I started
[Laughter]
open mic at Kohl's and you get a good
crowd we saw somebody who's that there
Mary Lee Monroe Mary Lee yeah dog she
lit up coals like yeah how it was like
explosive right oh I think she did a
four to five minute set but it was
immediately like I never seen an open
mic set like that which that [ __ ] just
exploded well like I feel sorry for what
cuz she had just did that early he just
did that said at the Laugh Factory a
little wild for comic all's we smoked a
blunt we kick in it she's like I'm gonna
get to get all 3ds jokes it's a damn
like three full minutes she's like watch
me get it man she went in there cuz you
know how to open mics I call this like
people it mean you have some people do a
few good says some it's over Mike so
it's all over the place some people
coming in very loose some people just
yelling for no reason because it goes
late it goes late I mean that drink if
you waiting to go 34th on over my
exactly you gotta do something like 130
yeah yeah that's crazy but she's that
[ __ ] Jesus Christ I'm glad I'm
that going right after a die-hard Bears
fan but the draft was yesterday
people don't seem happy about the draft
you know like the last few years it
looks disgusting it's weird I can't even
watch I could even watch out the five
games this year without being like I say
I'm not gonna be stressed out watching
[ __ ] everything yeah this done if
they're not gonna win I'm gonna tell you
what happened
I almost turned into Oakland Raiders
watch it not a fan just like I'll see
what they I did does they date they
honestly wants a writ remind me of an
old old [ __ ] team they were scoring
some good defense they fans ain't whack
yeah
they fantasy you know Oakland people I
feel bad for them too many lost a team
to Vegas that's [ __ ] crazy when does
that start
does it start this season next season I
think it's I think they played last
season in Oakland I'm the Buddy you
wanted that [ __ ] game what they play
well mostly the Oakland
good fans a piss I piss they are this
well I'll be attending in some of the
Vegas baby
[Laughter]
yeah I think they signed it it's Idol
yeah
Marshawn Lynch's son he's coming back
yeah I didn't do this crazy have you
ever like met this man no yo I forgot
what [ __ ] city I was in and I've got
to go to the club hey like I see this
group of [ __ ] riding these regular
bikes like in the middle of the street
yeah it is Marshawn Lynch and a budget
homies on regular bicycles going to the
flood in the middle of the street like
[Music]
it was the crazy at'll okay yeah it was
the way I've never seen no [ __ ] like
that and they all part made bikes it's
like getting in shape ye go to the club
hey that dude you know what I like about
him man he is himself to the fullest in
interview they know what he doing yeah
I'm glad he coming back I still hate
that Super Bowl man that they run that
[ __ ] ball that [ __ ] drives me [ __ ]
crazy why would you gamble on it or you
just hate if I'm a sports fan sports fan
yeah
I can't gamble man I can't get some [ __ ]
I can't control like if I can't play in
the game [ __ ] my camels [ __ ] I
don't know you shoot you on that you'll
shoot dice or play poker or something
yeah I shoot dice ain't a poker guy
let's just that [ __ ] too intense I've
started watching that [ __ ] on TV and I'm
just like this is this [ __ ] these
[ __ ] got heart
the other people is gonna keep us they
don't look a healthy yeah [ __ ] probably
people do not look at this is really
slow just the game itself just having to
wait out so you have a good hand if I if
I when I play Paul good to couples on
the plate I just end up going all-in by
the third hands brush just see what
happens yeah usually doesn't work out
well and it's always a good strategy
when you watch poker as always my [ __ ]
is playing with chips sounds the whole
time that's why everyone's got weird
habits and we're here buddy on the speck
yeah it is it's strange you have to be a
[ __ ] weirdo to be good at poker I
think so yeah for sure
you know so did you had a I see your
kids a lot on Instagram and they had two
acting debut in what project well
they've been in a couple things so they
debut was really on my special first can
I open up my special oh yeah they were
backstage right yeah I did open I really
got that from Damon Wayans special when
he did that with his kids
oh those dumpers [ __ ] and then they did
my MTV show acting out they played
themselves maybe was really good at that
and then Judah booked a role on
Carmichael show yeah
and it's kind of based on that jarana
hit me I was like yo Jude was really
good just watch the sketch - he's really
good at like and it's so [ __ ] up I
kind of feel bad about this but so it
was another kid that played my son and a
movie I did same ages Judah and his kiss
that dad called me he texts me since
then to actually oh yeah I put a word in
for me coming in to read for the part
like hey man look could you look kid
he's dope he played my son in a movie
he's like well you know I mean also I
mean you could put Judah on tape and not
wait a minute yep so they had you to put
himself on tape and he killed my auntie
record it was so such a funny bad dad
and recorder cuz she talking in the
background
yeah you don't have to realize - he only
got like five and we can just do them
back-to-back it was there like it did
Indian what's your name life is like she
just doing a bad acting like she's
auditioning off-camera it's kind of
weird [ __ ] and I'm like you can't talk
about Jenny yeah on this [ __ ] this is
actually going to producers please take
that little [ __ ] upstairs it
can't be no noisy because it was too
much going on the first table tonight
[ __ ] Joe answer but Judah was so [ __ ]
good man yeah that [ __ ] they flew him
here you know I mean last year your
audience time it was impeccable and [ __ ]
and if I ever had a weird as proud as a
moment of my life and I almost [ __ ] up
the scene cuz I'm in the scene with him
but to watch him doing that was so light
and I was froze oh [ __ ] I'm in the show
literally everybody's watching everybody
looking at me but oh [ __ ] I got a line
yeah cuz he was so [ __ ] good it was
like weird to watch that [ __ ] like
natural and an audience [ __ ] letter
so I remember I think was noticing I was
walking across him just waving just to
be eaten natural but it wasn't like
uncomfortable for me everything was just
real cool be careful you know what they
say but the child child stars can't let
him get too big too fast I don't know
what the most weirdest negative talk
about how proud he was of his kid get on
that cocaine
[Music]
[Laughter]
Instagram comments his proudest moment
as a father
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey can I tell Katya real about how
Hannibal I feel woke up from being drunk
tried to play that theremin and crash
the dining room table and went to bed
I'm going back over everybody or footage
like a detective I've gone sober since
then when that since then since a few
days ago I think I'm uh I want to try to
totally quit drinking we had too much
[ __ ] to do man what [ __ ] to do to be
drinking and act I've got them building
I had a rap I had this podcast
Behrman got the theremin practice their
flights to catch constantly that doesn't
go well with drinking not at all
helicopters tonight like I like sober
Hannibal it's tough man yeah I'm about
to a and bad news backstage writers no
more bottles backstage it's goddamn oh
my new rider my new rider my new rider
yoga teacher one yogurty one yoga
teacher that's a good vibes and a
peaceful spirit I think honestly and all
and honestly everything do you need to
do that for your next show what put that
on one and then record what happens just
put it on there like well Zeus is down
as a masseuse is backstage sometimes
right would they they wouldn't they
would what will they give you a bow you
say honor me I think most requests
reasonably honored if you give them
enough time don't we hit him oh [ __ ] up
two hours ativan
you're new to the world with your
booties you know you like give them a
couple weeks notice at least so yoga
teacher for an hour some a hundred bucks
that's like a request to the last I
wonder what they get the cheapest yoga
teacher they get there I just want my
rider to make it on The Smoking Gun a
one of them website you see what
Hannibal Buress is comedian Hannibal
Buress is outrageous writer orange juice
it's a big-ass mosquito just flew
through the house it's something but
it's no diet than that creme and that's
gnats day I think that I think that
would that would might get some press
you know where I think we'll do it
stand-up live in Phoenix Arizona
stand-up live there yeah great they're
great hosts I remember not you know
Hannibal Buress likes pineapples on his
writer yo and we were Phoenix and they
had all the all the usual suspects they
had the ginger ale the had the Jameson's
and celery had a can of did old
pineapples and a came to the manager
came in there hey everything cool
he kind of caught a side I had a can and
I sneaked a can took it out yeah I came
back with a real last pineapple cut Wow
somebody lost a job for leaving a can of
Planet oh I think
tongue-lashing maybe how dare you bring
that I wasn't there I wasn't there to
see it I just
pineapples diced pineapples Rick Ross
told me about that give me a give me a
good one line joke I could do this too
I'm not a one Lanikai wish I could do
one line like a killer
you gotta have a couple of like just
Street jokes I have no one line of jokes
I wish I did
Lia I remember him Addie I used to do
that [ __ ] it was the vaudeville [ __ ]
needs to be so funny like I'm terrible
right you got one of those yeah I cuz I
just want to try this I'm trying to get
my chops right alright you ready
well you're the five fingers say to the
face slap yeah this girl called me and
she was mad cuz I Texas Soleil she said
why you text me so late I say stay woke
[Music]
you got one Hannibal what do you tell
the woman with two black eyes nothing
you already told her twice
[Music]
[Laughter]
what did the what did the Jewish guy
what did the Jewish pedophile Saints
what did the Jewish pedophile say to the
kids what hey take it easy on a candy
I love that one that's funny
this is a joke I forgot who I her to say
who I hurt they said it Oh roast battle
to this girl's they says she has she has
on she's in an on and off relationship
with a boyfriend is on when he sees her
body is off what he sees her face that
was just real yeah I was damn I love
rose battle man those bottles a crate
the energy in it that should be insane
Dave Rose battle at The Comedy Store
they say such mean [ __ ] to each other I
would never do one mm-hmm no I wouldn't
do it I do a regular Rose cuz the jokes
get spread out they get spread amongst
everybody like a like a standard Rose
but not a battle standard let them roast
you I have come he said you what did you
do well people roasted you uh for the
prestige for the prestige of the roast
yeah maybe
depends on where I was mentally at that
time in my life if I was able to handle
those type of jokes sometimes you can
yeah like I'm gonna beat your ass
sometimes you think you can and after
that forty night hi I'm square up with
this dude where the lose would ever
bully fight that's crazy
hmm just a weird mind state to be in
even when I did the Bieber roast it was
I did it because it was a new was gonna
be a lot of eyeballs on it but it's just
a mind state in it leading up to it it
was just weird to be pacing in my
apartment think about something mean
about Martha Stewart and then just think
that somebody was writing a mean [ __ ]
for Martha Stewart to say about me she
paid him office he paid the [ __ ] out of
somebody
no I think just the staff I think Tony
I think Tony his cliff wrote a lot of
her stuff if I'm not mistaken hmm yeah
wait did she added did she have a joke
about you yeah what did she say she said
I look like a gingerbread man and got
left in the oven too long that's too
funny it felt like if a teacher could
talk about the kids
yeah that's hers hit so much cuz the
jokes were funny and also she had a
persona to go from you sit like so
everybody else kind of Shack making a
joke about snoop or Kevin Hart making a
joke about snoop those kind of jokes in
art is unless you have a very weird
angle it's kind of interchangeable Oh
Shaq's big and dumb chat
well Kevin Hart is little and loud it
crystally look like a douchebag in
etosha Lazaro's he's a girl she's a
[ __ ] so she's the girl here so this
makes jokes about being a girl and I'm I
just knew it went to jail Pete Davis
City looks weird and it's just you know
for a roast cuz it's is some roast for
the most part you hitting the base thing
and so her angle is I'm this cooking
lady and you remember why you don't
expect me to be here at all yeah and I'm
about to just that yeah let him fly very
seriously cuz you don't know where she's
coming from
yeah and you expect them at a bar
there's usually a lot of time they pick
her good actually the interesting
question how does she get [ __ ] who's
the one Ann Coulter bombs so hard that
one was harsh
she's just horrible though but I mean
her jokes weren't like huge but everyone
went after her ass just the energy man
people you can feel like you know
it's Martha Stewart felt people on her
side yeah perform you could feel people
on your side and my Jail so she'll
[ __ ] goddamn she sank to my [ __ ]
it's so great that you meeting her was
[ __ ] great Pete was [ __ ] great
Atlanta I was drunk on that because we
won't stage I mean I don't know what it
cuz I think it cuts down to two hours
but it really was about three total
hours and just sitting on stage
sunglasses
yep I don't several pairs of sunglass I
was doing I was doing my own Eric Andre
trick where I brought like six pairs of
sunglasses with me and hit him and so I
would switch out sunglasses so whenever
the camera will cut to me I would have a
want a different pair of sunglasses
yeah it's a funny little visual I mean
because beyond that you just they're
kind of laughing and just have fun with
it also just drinking cuz it's just
something uncomfortable about being
onstage the whole time while not doing
anything weird you just up top all the
lights on you but do they go do it go
all the way through straight or do they
take breaks
it's breaks but you know there's a
couple minute break we you know chat for
a little bit but then you back to your
seat on stage under lights and looking
at in the crowd to have a drink bunch of
badass chicks there yeah it was a decent
it was a decent yeah this is more like
now just kind of we just talking now
[Laughter]
[Music]
they then with a podcast but not me now
we've really revered out of podcast
territory
[Music]
we talk a lot about Chicago juke music
and [ __ ] on here
[Music]
[Music]
Oh to watch did 15 you haven't working a
long time and I think I just I work i
genuinely worry about tearing my ACL how
do you find it coming up we will to hear
verses in Chicago stand-up material it's
hard to hear because I don't like I
don't like I can't work it out right
away here like I hate going up here with
new [ __ ]
yeah these [ __ ] want to do
whatever they think making it is yeah if
you personally like they are making it
they don't try to do whatever the [ __ ]
you doing and you tell the true story to
you walking up to the club again today
yeah this is insane I just did this [ __ ]
last night I still a bit yeah and Plus
this audience is not to me a real hearty
so that you feel like the audience is
deer trying to get on to it's kind of
weird
Chicago such a real dope people really
got off work needed here yeah so you
know we have somebody in the audience
like yeah already interesting I've never
heard anything like I've never heard
anyone put it that way before but that
makes sense yeah I mean like I missed it
about Chicago that's why I try to go
home like when I when I want to do a new
hour some which is what I miss about
jokes nose
I'm gonna just do this out here and see
what the fun this is when this place is
gonna make what the next thing I do you
know what I do on the road is here you
know I mean but yeah I go I be on thirst
mode to go up lately so I've been going
up a lot more hair lay just cuz I've
missed the stage and [ __ ] yeah and
that's good to count ask if anything's
weird says get out is the excite lab it
but I was almost shell shocked the first
time I went up after the movie is like I
almost forgot that I was a crowd pop oh
man dude soon as I walked it was
cheering for like three minutes and it's
like God it kind of not flux to me but
that feels yeah okay hey like it even
looking at the faces like I mean I'm a
little more used to it now but it's just
funny like once they see you like they
hear your name like that it's the
initial applause and is to get on stage
again it's that that other way that the
seller like where people don't know my
name I'm just a familiar face that's
crazy like maybe the moment I was like
like I guess to get used to even like
what you like I remember doing a show
discography which is so funny I like
that me and chance over there show of
you crazy show people know the [ __ ] you
get people were kind of who's this which
answers [ __ ] and says was already
popping but yeah that's it a general
public like that I don't think you like
but like a fish
was to happen now like yeah all right
man all right having me mad
thanks for having thanks for coming
through
thanks for coming through here
Carmichael show may 31st 31st first two
seasons available on Netflix
yeah relevant the hour-long comedy
special available on Netflix get out
coming out DVD DVD may 23rd and catch me
on his season insecure oh [ __ ] we will
secure also nominated for MTV two
nominations were sad in this [ __ ]
was
[Music]
son
[Music]
listen listen was listen listen
it's like watching two kids who couldn't
make noise in the house growing up
[Music]
yeah yeah thanks Ralph thank you Robert
[Laughter]
[Music]